the German election is over an Angela
Merkel will remain Chancellor this week
conflict zone is in Berlin and my guest
is German politician on elites he is a
member of the European Parliament and
the Social Democrats who have just
suffered a stunning defeat now that the
votes are counted worse Germany headed
[Music]
Anneliese welcome to conflict zone the
German election is over and your party's
candidate Martin Schultz didn't manage
to convince enough voters that he should
to be the next German Chancellor he
failed miserably yes we failed miserably
as a party and we had a swing which was
interesting last January where we very
close actually same level up at that
time your candidate got 100 percent from
your party I think it was a little bit
too optimistic at that time well it was
not a question of to be optimistic was
the question if he is convincing the
party to be the leader and to run as a
Chancellor candidate and that was at the
same time during the lender elections
nobody wanted him to participate in the
campaigns exactly that happened in
northern Australia where the decision
was been taken not to include the
federal politics into this how can this
be you elect a few months before the
federal election and you star and you
don't allow him to participate in London
elections well there has been already
been set also by our party leaders that
that is was a decision which was not a
right one nevertheless we did I think
still did very well with Martin Schwartz
as a candidate who knows what had
happened if you would not have run the
campaign we have this is a very cynical
well we have angry you did well a little
bit more than 20% and you are saying you
did well as the SPD no I no no I said we
might have done not as good as we still
did less than 20 that's not be possible
look at this is a disaster what you are
just saying well the party without
Schult could have even had less than 20%
yes could have had and yes
that this is a disaster was said already
in our interview it is a brutal disaster
in particularly that we have now a
right-wing populists entire European
party we are coming speaker so we have a
new new shifting in the party situation
as such what did nothing shows do wrong
that's a question we have to look into
the party and I cannot give you an
answer don't have any idea I don't have
an idea yet but we have discussed
numerous situations if he should have
made certain things more clear on what
we want to run on social equality any be
some examples in to run a European
campaign as well Corbett much more
forward martin run on european politics
but i think after the change that back
home bought to france also the situation
from the European perspective got a bit
better that people saw that the pressure
might not be as high nevertheless we
have the right-wing party now in the
Europe in the German parliament and in
that regard we should have stressed that
this is the duty of a candidate to make
clear that this is a misunderstanding he
didn't well that's what I said we had
should have had maybe some more points
clear and not this broad topic but
nevertheless I still am very convinced
that we have a very strong program and
we've worked on so many topics other
parties didn't work we worked on the
topic and he made it clear that we don't
want to rise our budget for defense the
way the Conservatives want to do that we
want to spend money but we were not hurt
or broadcast on that issue also for the
European perspectives to change the
weapons export from the European Union
it's a strong point but this was not
taking in consideration by the voters
and that's what we have to acknowledge
us so who is responsible the voters who
didn't understand you candidate or
perhaps your candidate in your party who
did it understand the voters I wouldn't
put it like a blame game on responsible
why did you
lose trust we lost trust because we were
not able to deliver for example and we
were not hurt what we achieved in the
coalition we did wonderful situations I
was running four years ago in the
campaign as a candidate I was fighting
for minimum wage and the CDU was
strictly against it and said that this
is turning the business down the
opposite is effect we do have minimum
wages now but it was not acknowledged by
the voters knowledge by the I'm not
blaming I'm just saying that we did a
lot of mistakes no we set the minimum
wage and this is a big success for
Germany particular for East Germany if
you look at the wages situation there
it's the third election where the SPD
failed to beat Angela Merkel the Germans
don't trust your party to govern the
country why that I cannot answer because
if you can't answer that there will not
be a future for your party well that is
not true the Situationists times you
lost three times you couldn't convince
the Germans I'm asking you why and you
don't have an answer well the answer is
as I said before that the grand
coalition situation is we have also an
austere therefore similar situation that
don't help to have a political debate we
haven't had a political debate and
that's something I'm really also calling
on Angela Merkel that she didn't allow
and she's not interested to debate
political topics and that is a very new
this is a very crucial point did is 18
crucial topics we agree that Germany is
a democratic state for sure so with all
due respect to angle a miracle she's
allowing or not nobody is forbidden you
to discuss to have debates you don't
need the permission of Angela Merkel
well this is not true when you look at
the campaign in particular and election
campaigns are the crucial time for
democracy that you debate where you come
out where you
contradict each other on your aims on
your goals and you have the situation in
the states where you have at least three
to four debates Angela Merkel was first
of all telling the journalists how she
is willing to do a debate and second she
did she didn't do a second third or
fourth that is something for debating in
politics the one debate you are talking
right is not really the only issue thing
happening which is going on during an
election your candidate had weeks months
of time to tell to the Germans what is
the point of the SPD and he didn't
succeed giving you an example for
decades the SPD was seen at the best
political ambassador for social methods
those times are over your brand is
fading isn't it well we're picking up
exactly on that topic and we did pick up
on that topic on the European election
campaign we are speaking about the
German elections right but also in the
German our main topic for social
equality the Social Democrats didn't say
whether or not they wanted a center-left
coalition with greens and the Left Party
what this a crucial mistake not giving
the voters a clear choice know you don't
know how parties can develop if you look
at the Left Party and the Left Party was
here the crucial point that you
advocated that well as I just said the
decision has not been taken away that
this is an option and if the Left Party
would have swing in in some foreign
political points there might have been
an ability to correlate together and so
coalition comes from different parties
and so that option was then been brought
down throughout the lesson the SPD
didn't take any decision they didn't say
either yes with the left's perhaps or
never with the left perhaps the voters
didn't know what will be your reaction
at the
the elections I don't think that the
coalition question was a decision to
vote or not to vote for the SPD let me
ask you something else with this
election results in mind shouldn't
Martin Schultz step down as a leader of
the SPD I mean 21% how can you continue
to be a leader of the this disaster what
did the message the message from my side
as a party member is that he should stay
the leader of the party if he wants to
be why he lost he lost never before the
Social Democrats since 45 had such a bad
result
well we didn't drop to that extent like
other countries have dropped like the
Netherlands for example the question is
how the party construct and reconstructs
its topics its approach and its
communication to the public that our
points we worked on that we succeeded
yes he's very credible he is he is
credible for the future he can be the
leader for the future after this
disaster
absolutely that had happened many times
in history that people didn't succeed in
their election but they still kept the
leader of a party we lost the election
that's why I'm very happy that they are
straightforward saying that they're not
going into a grand coalition again it
makes sense on the situation on the
right wing AFD
but it also makes sense that we have to
have a power play in Germany and our
politics moves well with a good
opposition and a strong leadership and
coalition's are there for a pop and
that's why I truly believe it was a
right step to decide yesterday already
that due to the situation we go into the
opposition and the purpose he's going to
be a strong opposition it happen against
opposition the concern AFD
is the first far-right party to make it
into the
I stock since Nazi Germany if this is a
turning point for the country it is a
brutal turning point for the country
particularly that you have already right
candidates who made it through into the
German parliament we have the situation
to aft is in sec Sonya the strongest
party for not mistaken but also they
keep going well another incident every
third male voted aft in East Germany
private third right that is shopping and
the design it's shocking because not why
it is shocking why this happened that
every third male voter voted for the AFD
in general I think it's a lack of
political education and understanding of
political developments and trusting but
even being interesting in political
matters
this means a failure of more than 25
years of reunification no it means a
failure we have worldwide on political
education and people taking their share
in democracy not only going to vote but
also looking at what is happening and
listening to it and not being in this
situation as we look at now but let's
point it out
AFD representatives attracted attention
with racist anti Islamic and the
nationalist rhetoric little more than
13% of the Germans 13% of the Germans
supporting them nevertheless what does
it tell us about Germany in the year
2017 that tells us we have a big
mountain of work in front of us in the
regards what it means that in a country
with this history comes up again with
racism that neglecting the Holocaust
calling that we should be proud of the
gamma the German army in the first but
also in the Second World War
ever the AFT sets mr. Gowan said this is
so that you failed as BS
Beadie that new could we all receive
these daughters yeah we could attract
that let's let's not only look at the
SVD yes we could not check them but your
question goes actually in the direction
we have to look into why is it happening
and possible that every s you said every
third male voted for them in East
Germany and and is not interested in the
issues the AFT brings up as well being a
racist being an entire European and
being a radical party and we have I've
heard in a coffin story in the European
Parliament that she wants her bread said
for Germany that's what she announced
the day after the breaks that in the
European Parliament so and people don't
care and therefore the European Union as
such it's not a given we have to fight
for every day and so let's talk and
practice you do that and we are going to
do that as a strong so opposition party
that we don't give that to the airplane
and I'm very glad about that you gave it
what will be the future we will see but
let's talk about Europe it is you Europe
wide phenomena that nationalist and
populist parties are having increasing
success like open in Hungaria Kaczynski
in Poland Austria Denmark Norway
how do you explain that that is what you
can compare to Germany to the AFD and
also to foreign arsenal but also to the
[ __ ] ISM in the US but in Hungary and
in Poland these people are even governed
right they influence every decision in
Europe and the nationalists racist right
and they change their basic lower
situation look if you look at the
Constitutional Court in Poland the
government now is distracting it which
is and shouldn't be allowed by the
European Union I'm very glad that
timmermans and that the European
Parliament is strong against it or one
is supporting Poland and that
development that is the situation but
regardless of that let's talk about that
EU Commission President jean-claude
Juncker said quote for me Europe is more
or than just a single market more than
money more than the euro it was always
about values but these values as human
rights and the rule of law are in danger
what is the solution the solution is to
strengthen the political groups in
Poland and to also be strict strict
against the government's from Poland and
Hungary that you are well we are no you
are not let's talk about how Europe
defends its values in his State of the
Union speech October Glencoe also said
member states have gave final jury
decision to the EU Court of Justice the
judgments of the court have to be
respected by all the rule of law is not
optional in the European Union it's a
must
Hungary refusing to take in refugees
took their case to the European Supreme
Court they lost Congress Prime Minister
Albin said he didn't care about the
court's ruling he can how can such a
country still be a member of the
European Union not accepting a decision
of the Supreme European port we're still
being there no consequences no sanctions
nothing happened well the nothing is not
right first of all here you see a loss
of the constructing of the European
Union we have not thought and considered
even that in particular Hungary but also
Pradhan who were actually the breeding
grounds for democracy for Eastern Europe
in particular Poland supported us with a
round table East Germany wouldn't have a
peaceful revolution if you wouldn't have
had pawn in its module this house once
and I and now he's about the reality
right the reality is that it was not
constructed into the situation that
countries could go so far out of there
that we got this but even don't you did
didn't and don't try to take a decision
oh yeah hungry there is not an official
decision against well the situation is
the following that we have article 7
where you can bring these countries into
a more difficult situation on taking
decisions and the European Parliament
calls for if you have different you
nothing happened let's take the Member
States and let's go straight to their to
the member state situation member states
have to pick that up the member states
have to even if this already is saying
that hungry would support Poland that
they would not like to take article 7
but we have to take it I am as a
parliamentarian straightforward to put
as much and high pressure as possible
yes this is it theory and no no the
reality is September 27th if that's why
I'm son member states didn't have
respect right the rule of law Poland
doesn't respect the rule of law in its
own country today no sanctions no
reactions
Hungary's president and the Prime
Minister Poland are laughing about your
principles well they're not laughing
only and it's also as a matter of fact
in the responsibility of the party
families and particularly the urban
party is in the party family of the
cdu/csu and they have to also be
straight forward to the party members in
the European Parliament to tell them
that if they don't take up the rule of
law they might be also this is a
responsibility which goes into the
partisan fair but I totally agree with
you that we have to take more and
drastic actions towards this correctly a
question if member states of the
European Union don't respect them
aquatic values how can be the EU taken
seriously well you said it's not taking
any actions yes there are actions being
taken and you know that things take a
Member State I just don't respect them
Radek Valley
right we have to set up the rule of play
for the European Union towards the
situation and that the minority rights
could be overrun by voting by the member
states that these countries have to
respect and that sanctions are possible
this has not been built into the system
and yes we have to readjust the European
system on that issue
it's I really feel that it's not only
about the you Martin shil said the US
president Trump Russian President Putin
and Turkish president are the one behave
like quote autocratic rulers is it
appropriate to compare Trump with Putin
and everyone well you can compare every
person to every person but the question
is what you kind of make out of it but
if you look at is it appropriate I mean
America as it is a democracy still
Russia not check and balances are
existing right well if you look at there
he didn't compare the United States he
compared the leadership of their US and
yes Trump is very reliable right now and
responsible in many situations being the
United Nations for example and calling
for national approaches and multilateral
istic system isn't the way the United
Nations was set up for and should be set
up for and therefore yes we have to be
careful but we also have to be
straightforward on the issues on how a
party or how a leader is taking action
in the world no one before Trump called
to take up the atomic bomb in a crisis
and that issues have to be taking very
seriously have to be also confront let's
talk for a minute about Catalonia one of
the biggest problems in Europe in his
State of the Union speech Janka called
for more United Nation but Spanish
authorities tried to stop the referendum
by detaining officials suspending
Catalonian police and replacing them
with central police forces blocking
Internet do you support these measures
by the Spanish government that's a
crucial situation or a very critical
situation we have there if you look at
the rule of law I do understand that if
the setup is not being built up rightly
for a referendum it couldn't be done and
therefore you could also not accept the
result whatever is coming up if anyone -
do you support what the Spanish
authorities are doing yes I know yes -
the X phase is a very political
statement yes and no well it's a very
interesting answer so let me rule it out
what is the priority the priority well
you can act and you have to confront the
situation by the rule of law but putting
people into prison or putting them into
custody it's a situation I'm very
critical of because that doesn't help a
situation on the ground if there is
anything happening as a result of a
referendum and you do not then have to
accept it has to accept has not to
accept it's not to accept right but part
about the question of the rule of know
about detaining people to that extent
it's a very critical situation we
haven't had in the European Union but
what we can see by this example is
instead of a more United EU we are
confronted with nationalism separatism
anti-democratic developments also now in
Germany how long can this go on without
causing serious damage to the European
idea I mean in Belgium flam's also
separatist movements Scotland we have so
many problems in this issue what is
going on with the nationalism the
separatism right and regarding of a
united Union of Europe there you just
mentioned them all our biggest
challenges but coming back to chuttan
Scotland there you have actually a
situation where they want to be a member
of
European Union and their discussion of
the brexit on the Scottish question
could be an actually very interesting
one in the future it might destroy the
Union itself of the great British
Islands and therefore we are looking
like seriously threats as you mentioned
Poland and Hungary but also the
separatism movements in different
countries I don't see Belgium right now
as a critical situation but the general
EU it's critical for sure in this
situation better or worse than ever
well it's better because we haven't had
war and if you compare to the war
situation I'm an historian and we better
give every opportunity to build Europe
on every construction site we can build
it up and time thank you very much for
being on conflict so it was a pleasure
thank you thank you very much as well
[Music]